here with reaction Fox News contributor
former Speaker of the House Newt
Gingrich so you raised the question
we've talked about it twice but I want
to look at your question differently at
this point and that is you you feel
after the midterm you have to rethink
every election model you have believed
in your entire political career and as a
great historian my question is my only
fear about Georgia is not that Herschel
can't win I think he can the question is
will Republicans that have been reticent
to buy into early voting and mail-in
voting are they going to continue to
allow the Democrats to rack up these
early voting lead numbers and
mathematically almost make it impossible
for somebody to come back if you can't
change the system don't you have to
eventually just buy into it and do it
better than they're doing
well I would say based on the early
voting we saw on Saturday that
Republicans were turning out at least as
much as Democrats was a huge turnout
Statewide in the counties that had begun
voting that early and I think for a
couple reasons one is that you have the
most powerful and most popular
politician in the state Governor Brian
Camp has thrown his weight into the race
on behalf of Herschel and I think he's
mobilizing the thousands and thousands
of Georgians who had voted for him and
then skipped the senate race a second
Georgia this Saturday will be in the
Super Bowl in the uh the sec's
championship game The Last Time Georgia
was undefeated for the entire regular
season Herschel Walker was playing at
Georgia so I think he has with Vince
Dooley's ad which he made just before he
passed away endorsing Herschel I think
commercial has a certain emotional pool
for a lot of Georgians and third a lot
of Republicans are beginning to realize
being 50 50 is very different than being
5149 in the Senate at 50 50 you have
power sharing on every single committee
at 51.49 the Democrats control every
single committee so this is a very big
race and I think Georgians are beginning
to respond to the idea they don't want
Warnock who's a hard left big tax
increase Beyond Joe Biden frankly Beyond
Bernie really of the Socialist kind of
guy they don't want Warnock being the
deciding vote in the U.S Senate and I
think you're going to see Herschel do
very well and I do think you're going to
see a lot of Republicans turn out before
election day
if Herschel runs tell me if you think
I'm wrong I think the odds that Joe
manchin switching parties is far greater
than it's ever been for this reason when
he was going against the administration
ending the legislative filibuster and
going against Chuck Schumer his approval
rating was in the 70s since he went
along with the inflation reduction act
it's been now I think the last one I saw
was in the 30s now what's interesting he
was promised a pipeline if he would go
along with Schumer and Biden and then
after he went along with that deal
they didn't give them the pipeline and
they're not giving him the pipeline and
Joe Biden just before November 8th made
the comments about eliminating all
coal-fired power plants and ending all
Drilling in America completely now that
will destroy the economy of West
Virginia if Herschel won would that give
an opportunity would it be a possibility
that Joe manchin says I've had it you
broke your word you broke your promise
to not only me but the people of my
state I'm out of here
well look I think it's it's clearly
possible that Mansion at that point
would decide to switch parties and join
the Republicans uh he uh if if in fact
Warnock wins they won't need Mansion
they'll be able to govern at 50 50 with
mansion voting no and they'll have
Kamala Harris be the tide-breaking vote
but if uh Herschel wins then all of a
sudden
I think once again you have enormous
power in mansion and he's got to decide
does he want to go back home and run for
reelection in which case he'd be vastly
better off as a republican I doubt if he
can win as a democrat in West Virginia
because it's so alienated by the
left-wing radical
anti-fossil fuels policy of the Biden
Administration and the the cultural
awokeness which is very very opposite of
the values of the people of West
Virginia explain to me why Biden is
allowing a country that we as the United
States states don't even recognize as a
duly elected president why would he make
a deal with Maduro for energy when we
have more energy than they do and we can
produce a cheaper cleaner faster here
why would he be looking for another why
did he give immunity to MBS who he
called the murderer why would he be
talking to the Iranians we don't need
their oil or gas or any energy why would
he be making enemy countries Rich when
we could be making America rich and also
help out our allies in Western Europe
you know in 1984 the Republican National
Convention Ambassador Gene Kirkpatrick
gave an amazing speech in which he
talked about the Democrats as blame
America First and went through a whole
series of things and said in every case
they blame America First well the
evolution of the democratic party
towards its new uh as I say they have
two Wings weird and insane and that
Evolution has led the Democrats to be
undermine America first so when they
have a choice of a policy that would
strengthen America or undermine America
they automatically pick undermine so you
could be pumping oil as you point out
absolutely correctly you could get oil
and gas out of Western Pennsylvania you
could get it out of Eastern Ohio you get
out of West Virginia North Dakota
Oklahoma Texas Louisiana all across the
country or you could rip off the
American industry industry lay people
off [ __ ] us as a country and buy it
from dictators around the world you you
know the the logical rational
explanation is that Biden and the weird
and insane wings of the democratic party
believe that undermining America
is the best thing for the human race
that a weak America a helpless America
is better for the human race and so
they're prepared if Trump was for
America First therefore America lasts
and you're seeing it in all these
decisions
wait till everybody's going to see their
heating bills there are predictions of
30 to 45 percent increases and by the
way shortages that may actually result
in blackouts in New England this winter
and if that happens that would be a
disaster hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else